my odds are 1 to 23. you guys if you bet
on me and i win you'll become a millionaire
this is going to be awesome here and the game
should be beginning shortly so you know you know
charlie better than any one here at thechest.com
streaming community how how uh how pumped is he
to be back here uh in pog champs and and uh what
what chances you give him to maybe be one of the
better players he's definitely pumped that i
know he's also definitely nervous and i always
point this out these uh stars these streamers
they are used to broadcasting to millions and
millions of people danny but there's something
about sitting behind a chess board be it a virtual
chess board or a real chessboard that brings out
all the anxiety and i actually really like that
so charlie he's experienced he knows what this
is like at the same time we're going to watch
his time consumption and uh i don't know too much
about code miko but i think she's put in the work
well right now she started out pretty pretty
well she played some natural developing moves
right i mean this is um not the most traditional
approach against the sicilian and charlie handles
it like a pro with e6 and d5 but but there's
some risk in an opening like this if if miko can
can play aggressively in the center early
on maybe she'll maybe she'll be okay here
yeah for sure she needs to strike in the center
d4 get her pieces out quickly rookie once she
goes d3 she's doing everything right preparing the
development of her dark square bishop and charlie
quickly focusing on getting that king to safety
uh by castling yeah bishop v7 supernatural move
but this is this is a great start i mean even
though we were saying d4 i actually kind of
like that she played d3 because it protects
against c4 maybe maybe she she would have got
her bishop trap so this is some really awesome
principal chess she's bringing out her pieces and
all right now i'm nervous i'm excited i'm excited
too this is great and they're both getting their
pieces out doing everything right mikko brings
her last piece out charlie still has that dark
light squared bishop to bring out which he can
put on a bunch of different squares and they
are following the fundamentals to the letter
gaming yeah and you know something about the
way she's playing two just the tempo of it right
even if this is the most traditional approach
against charlie sicilian she's playing all these
developing moves with confidence if you look at
the fact that she has nine and a half minutes so
i'm going to do the early kind of hecarim call
to action and just say i kind of think she's
underrated at 3 33 he tends to kind of look at
the ratings and see how they play and i i would
say now that she's probably underrated at 300.
she absolutely is and i completely agree with
you just by these first moves uh she's showing
complete command of the fundamentals and uh you
don't do that you know if you're if you've had
one chess lesson so she's definitely been putting
in the work now charlie um i'm gonna be straight
up with you danny he he has a big weakness in
terms of his time consumption when he's playing
casually he he plays confidently but when he's
on the big stage sometimes he freezes so we'll
see whether he can uh he can control that here in
this game i'm not gonna do anything too crazy here
he's illuminating even his thoughts here tanya
so deep you can't express them so do you
express that right i'm just gonna
say we don't care about double pawns
let's let's come back here to the main board
and i played bishop f4 and point one i'm
pretty sure she had accidentally clicked it
for a pre-move or she or she was pre-moving
which would be you know kind of a surprise kind
of uh you know high-level play there for her to
pre-move and and maybe not a very smart one
with with charlie playing b5 but let's throw
to code miko now for the first time and see
what she's thinking about it's okay it's fine
oh my god here he comes here
comes the pummeling guys um
the pummeling i have not been
looking forward to but kinda yes
oh jesus that's scary
all right well i guess we'll have oh
jesus that's not good um um you know what
you know what guys you know what i'm just spence
i'm just gonna go
here
not a great move yep
uh hey more than six news okay
probably does it
all right
that's what she's missed
oh
she's playing so fast that's that's the
thing that i would advise her yep oh
shut up shut up everyone oh wait what oh
i didn't even oh i didn't even say hey
you know what guys you know what we we did it
it was more than six moves that's that's for
are we sure dreamers do we dream or do we meme
we do both when we dream a meme at the same
time there's nothing we cannot do we can achieve
everything you heard it you heard it from code
miko if you dream and meme anything's possible
dreaming and memeing together is a win here we
go it's going to be an awesome day we got mystery
ludwig up ahead we got crazy stuff charlie plays
e4 here we go and an e5 from code miko and the
vienna gambit is what charlie has been playing
over the last couple of weeks that's where white
goes f4 pretty quickly but here he develops his
vision yeah this is a really aggressive line
right obviously when you play f4 at some point the
f-file will lead the rook and bishop having a date
right there on f7 or at least they hope to and
the pressure becomes very very very very strong
very quickly depending on whether black knows what
to do so mikko already given it a think right here
right it's not the most common opening
which is part of the reason that uh
it's very effective because if you
can get your opponent out of their
comfort zone pretty early and you know the
ideas you get a pretty big edge on the clock and
often that translates into an advantage over
the board right well now already white has
the option to play f4 and you can also play d3
if you still want to sort of slow jam the idea
um of course you always have the option of
going back into a more traditional kind of
whatever that would be two nights four nights
but no as we already we already know because uh
because we have the profit here f4 is charlie's
weapon what do you think is gonna happen at some
point in the event when he plays against someone
who's prepared for his vienna how's that gonna go
well he's gonna have to tighten up the screws
because the thing with these openings right if
they work out for you you can score some quick
victories if you mess up the move order you
mess up one move it's a double-sided sword and
you can get in trouble pretty darn fast but uh
so far charlie's showing nice command of the
principles getting rid of the pin immediately
yeah and the risk as you said because if it goes
wrong what you've done is open up a lot of dark
squares but okay here we see an example of how
it goes right a lot a lot of times people don't
really realize how aggressive this line can
be and just like that your bishop is trapped
yeah kodmiko bishop trapped on one side
of the board and now it's strapped on the
other side of the board in the other game
and she does the right thing giving it up
for a pawn if you're losing a piece you
want to give it up for as much as possible
yeah she takes it that's a good move and i
and i again i think the only thing i would say
is obviously it's hard you know when you when
you feel like you're playing a stronger player
but i think that she maybe like we said in game
one thinks she's a little worse than she is and
and is playing kind of too fast if she if she
slows down a little bit you know um because the
openings she's had are very principled right she's
gotten pieces out she understands all of those all
of those development kind of ideas and we'll see
if she gets castled here it's the king of the
center yeah she's she's developing all our pieces
and you can't say it enough it's not that easy
to get into a situation we have command of the
principles and that's exactly what she has maybe
again maybe taking a little bit more time would
have been good but these unconventional positions
they can be hard to get your footing in but other
than that you know you could confuse or play for
that of magnus or maybe gary caspara yeah i mean
what would gary kasparov think about this position
well if only we had him on the show but danny
tim this reminds me of the match
against uh another corporate
do you think you think good russian
school boys gary was a busy man
would good russian school boys appreciate
the v tuber experience you think gary any
you know where i come from and i would say be
too worrying is i'm old school you know i like
flip phones you know notebooks in a button i can
definitely appreciate you know the the sort of the
rise you know the ai and you know i've spoken
about it even in colleges in it before but um
overall you know i'm quite approving of you know
the strength okay there you go thank you gary
um we'll uh maybe check in with you a little
bit later all right look at this move knight
h5 from her mikko puts that in on h5 it opens
up the check and we see charlie make his first
kind of odd move of the day let's listen into
code miko and see if she sees the check and
what she can do here drawing is important
but that's gonna get that guy so then you
uh no i wanna i wanna get rid of some
of my some of my pieces are so stuck and
that night on h5
exactly
oh [ __ ] i know what he's
trying to do he's trying to
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait i get what he's trying to do
um just depend on that one don't worry
don't don't panic don't panic everybody
don't panic okay don't panic just don't
panic nobody panic it's okay nobody panic
i'm not either no uh nobody i don't
understand why i can't move this
but um nobody panic stop penegate okay stop
yelling danny why are you panicking danny
why are you panicking now we'll see if
charlie can see how dangerous the g-file
is the uh computer's actually announcing
bait and six but let's see what charlie sees
yeah and what you can see here white is
up two pieces and there's also this g-file
white's got a rook positioned and facing
right at black's king and that pawn that
is covering the king is very flimsy you can
attack that pawn with a variety of pieces you
can bring your bishop out all the way to age
six and the pawn because it is binge of king
yeah the he's not he's not talking i
don't know how best to approach this mate
this is something i also need to work on i
see a lot of different mating options here
i see a ton of mating options i just don't
know like the best and fastest way of doing it
i'm just gonna push it up that's the best move
that's the fastest mate got it easy
queen is untouchable because of the thing to me
that looks okay if she comes here i can just take
the bishop he's nervous he's worried there's a
defensive resource somewhere but there isn't any
do i want to just take that with
any of the three pieces actually
doing her best block the g file
but unfortunately it's just
hold the pin oh yep now
it's and now it's made on g7
and there it is
wow that was a commanding attack there by
charlie he did not real talk he was he was
awesome so charlie just one quick question for
you do you feel uh similar to how you did in
pogchamps when do you feel like that experience
is making you less nervous or is it the sort
of same kind of sensation oh absolutely not i
think it's a lot more nerves this time because
i won the the losers bracket the consolation
participation trophy bracket and now i'm like
almost expected to win some games and i think
that sucks that is tough man having to play with
like an expectation to do well oh i was really
really excited i'm super nervous to go against
like literally chess jesus himself um but i was
just really happy that i did more than six moves
yeah no i think that's great that was one of
the finest performances i've seen in pogchamps
typically i'm slapping cheeks around six moves
you went all the way to like 12 in some cases yay
that's why i'm saying go more if we just do more
than six moves we're winning for me today amen
exactly these were good games good start to
the event and best of luck in in the next round
thank you so much thanks for having me
you